bernie sanders almost immediately after
the derrick chauvin verdict again
three guilty counts potentially decades
in prison
sentencing in eight weeks bernie sanders
using similar language to that which
many are are using and many of
our viewers used on the live stream
where we covered the verdict
that the chauvin verdict is
accountability
but it is not justice and it does not
fix issues
of systemic racism in the united states
bernie sanders sending a few tweets
let's look at them saying quote the
jury's verdict delivers accountability
for derek chovin
but not justice for george floyd real
justice for him and too many others can
only happen when we build a nation
that fundamentally respects the human
dignity of every person
bernie going on to say the trauma and
tragedy of george floyd's murder
must never leave us it was a
manifestation of a system that callously
devalues
the lives of black people finally
bernie's saying
our struggle now is about justice not
justice on paper
but real justice in which all americans
live their lives
free of oppression we must boldly root
out the cancer of systemic racism
and police violence against people of
color
so certainly this is a step forward
if it is a new era of
more police understanding that
they are in a position as uh um
police officers that can be dangerous
for them there's no denying that
they are in a position where they are
put into situations
that are by their nature difficult and
that require
exercising judgment about what is the
risk to them
and to others of the individuals that
they encounter but
the sort of free pass or close to free
pass that
it's not my opinion that statistically
there has been
understand over the last decade and a
half
as i mentioned earlier out of 140 cases
of charges against officers
for murder or manslaughter of the 97
cases that have been resolved
seven guilty verdicts okay that this may
be a change
in terms of what they can get away with
and much like when barack obama was
elected president
it didn't end racism in fact
it arguably coalesced racism and
xenophobia
and subsequently led to donald trump
understand the backwards nature of that
this is potentially a step forward but
pervasive ignorance is not going
anywhere
anytime soon it is maybe the start it is
maybe a glimmer of hope it would be
great if it were true
uh that this was some major resolution
to america's problems but it's not and
and
again i want to repeat something that i
mentioned in the first segment about the
verdict
it is an odd situation where
you have the state of minnesota
saying we are going to deal with what we
believe is a wrong that was committed
right the state's saying
from what we saw we we are charging
derek chovan and we are prosecuting
derek chauvin
but derek chovin is at least in a sense
a consequence of the policing system
overseen by that very same state of
minnesota and you could make a similar
analogy to other states
around the country different states
dealing with with issues of police force
to different degrees so
we are now going to have to see what it
what is next uh
president joe biden speaking last night
uh alongside
kamala harris and and others and saying
we
we now have a problem that hopefully we
can start to deal with
and the question of how is it going to
be dealt with and to what degree
and will police departments uh play a
role
as part of the solution or not and of
course police departments aren't one
thing and there are dramatically
different police departments in the
united states
to just as a reminder disclaimer i know
people get mad when i do this
i am not an abolish the police guy i am
a reformed the police guy and i have
extensive clips on our youtube channel
about why
that's my framework this is not you know
i know that there were some
who reacted to this by saying all cops
are bastards
abolish the police this guilty verdict
proves we get rid of police
go talk to them if you want to figure
out why they think that that's not my
view
i've made clear you know my eight to ten
point plan of uh police reforms that
that i would put in place so the
question i have for you and you can let
me know find me on twitter at deepakman
or elsewhere
um what do you hope this verdict means
and what do you think it most likely
means if anything bigger picture
all right find me on twitter deepakman
we'll take a quick break
and we will have extensive reaction from
all sorts of different people
to these three guilty verdicts that we
got yesterday